We are going to talk now a little bit more
about how we access the elements of the matrix
which represents an image from inside the
MATLAB environment. And we are going to do
this interactively from the command line tool.
We will start by loading an image, one that
we have seen a few times before. It is the
Mona Lisa image, has a PNG extension, and
we are going to convert it from colour to
grey scale because we have not really talked
about colour yet. And we have loaded the image
into our workspace, and I can use the toolbox
command about, to tell us a bit more about
that particular image.
It tells us that the image variable is of
the type uint8, that it is 700 pixels wide
and 677 pixels tall, and occupies 470 kilobytes
of memory.
What I am going to do now is to display the
image and again these commands should be pretty
familiar to you. And there is the Mona Lisa
image. And as we discussed before, we can
move around, we can click pixels and we can
look at the grey scale value. And we can click
a pixel there, in the middle of her eye. And
it has got quite a low value. It is in that
dark part of her eye.
Now, we access that variable directly from
the MATLAB environment, and I am going to
choose the row coordinate which is the vertical
coordinate in the image, that is 194 and the
column coordinate which is a horizontal coordinate
276. So remember we talked about this before:
we have to reverse the coordinates from the
u,v notation, horizontal and vertical coordinate
system to MATLAB’s row and column index
for matrices, and there we see that same value,
26, that is a low grey scale value, a dark
value which represents the intensity of that
pixel within her eye.
Another thing we can do with MATLAB is to
access not just a single pixel, but in fact
a block of pixels, and we do that using MATLAB’s
colon operator. So let’s choose all rows
between 180 and 210, and all columns starting
at 260, up to 290. When I hit enter, we are
going to see a large number of pixel values
scroll past. So I can roll back up and look
at all of them there.
So it has returned, in this case a matrix.
A small matrix; a sub-matrix of the original
image.
Let’s actually put that into a workspace
variable, and I will do that by coming back
and editing that command line.
There we go. So I have created a new variable
workspace called im2 and it is a 31 by 31
pixel image. And I can display that. And we
see an image, which is actually the eye of
the Mona Lisa.
This time instead of selecting a block of
pixels, I am going to choose a line of pixels.
I am going to do that by putting the result
into a variable called lin, and this is the
MATLAB variable that contains the original
image. I am going to select row 190 and all
pixels in columns between 260 and 290. And
here they are, these are the pixel values
along a short horizontal segment of the Mona
Lisa image. And I can plot that.
And here we see an intensity profile. Starts
off quite light, falls down the middle as
we go through the dark part of the Mona Lisa’s
eye, and then go to larger greyscale values
as we move back onto the pixels that comprise
her face.
There are a number of other interesting and
useful tricks we can do with a colon operator.
I am going to create another output image.
This time I am going to call it im3 and what
I am going to do is select again the Mona
Lisa image and I am going to choose all the
rows starting at 1 in steps of 4 up to end,
which is a special MATLAB variable which represents
the largest row number in the matrix. And
select all the columns again, starting at
1 in steps of 4 up to the largest column number
and create a new workspace variable called
im3 and I am going to display that image.
Here we go.
And what we can see now is that this image
has much lower resolution, we can see the
blockiness of the pixels, we can see in the
horizontal and vertical directions that there
are far fewer pixels in this image than there
are in the original and that is because what
we have done is chosen every fourth pixel
from both the horizontal direction and in
the vertical direction. We have reduced the
resolution of the image. So that is a quick
trick you can do with MATLAB, using the colon
operator.
The final thing that is useful to know about
the colon operator—I am going to create
yet another image, and this time what I am
going to do is I am going to choose the rows
starting at end, starting at the biggest possible
row number, going in steps of -1 working downwards,
until I get to row 1, and then I am going
to choose all of the columns from one up to
end.
You can probably imagine what this is going
to do. And there we go—we have flipped the Mona
Lisa upside down. One final quick tip is that
the last command that we typed; we can actually
make it a bit more concise. We need to write
that last part where we say all of the columns
from 1 to end, we can write that down very
simply just as colon. So where ever you have
colon to represent a column or row of a matrix,
it means all. We can think of it as a wild card operator.